vous faites caca comment vous ah si vous
êtes sûr que c'est le meilleur position
ben non faut croquer accroupi je vous
explique quand le rectum se remplit la
pression augmente à l'intérieur et c'est
ça qui vous donne envie de faire caca
mais regardez il y a un muscle qui
entoure le tuyau là juste en dessous du
rectum il s'appelle le muscle plus beau
rectal et quand on est assis ça tire
dessus du coup il est tendu ça fait un
coup de sur le tuyau et ça passe moins
bien alors que quand on est accroupi le
muscle se détend et ça met le rectum et
le trou de balle bien en face vous savez
comme les viseurs dans les avions de
chasse du coup le tuyau il est tout
droit et plouf direct alors c'est vrai
c'est pas facile de crotter accroupi si
vous faites ça par terre c'est pas
propre et si vous grimpez sur la lunette
des toilettes c'est dangereux mais ce
qui est important pour que le muscle
soit bien détendu c'est d'avoir les
jambes à 35 degrés par rapport au ventre
c'est à dire d'avoir les genoux au
dessus des hanches et pour ça il suffit
de s'asseoir et de mettre un truc sous
ses pieds pour les surélever essayez
vous me direz enfin non vous me direz
pas je préfère pas